questo pomeriggio molti di voi
realizzerà il sogno nel cassetto che si
porta dietro da quando è bambino
e questa premessa Meno male che non c'è
il soddisfatto rimborsato perché mi
mettere nei guai magari col sogno
qualcuno lo ha già realizzato qualcun
altro Invece ok non lo realizzerà
stasera però stasera metterà il primo
mattoncino per edificarlo questo grande
sogno
partiamo da un fatto gli esseri umani
non possono volare no gli esseri umani
non sono dotati di Ali che generano la
portanza tale per spiccare il volo
Eppure abbiamo avuto 200 mila anni di
tempo come razza umana Ma la natura a
quanto pare queste Ali non ce le ha date
Eppure volare è stato da sempre uno dei
sogni dell'uomo pensate a Icaro la
mitologia sappiamo tutti com'è andata a
finire queste Ali fatte di più Un
attaccate al corpo con la cera si
avvicina troppo al sole e precipita in
mare
Poi è arrivato Leonardo da Vinci che ha
progettato le prime macchine per il volo
Ma chi tra tutti si è avvicinato al
concetto dell'aviazione moderna per come
la conosciamo sono stati i fratelli
Wright
adesso di aerei ce ne sono di ogni
tipologia il mio preferito è quello che
ti permette di aprire il portellone
guardare giù e gettarsi sotto
Menomale che hanno inventato però i
paracadute Così chi lo fa lo può anche
raccontare perché vedo già qualcuno che
muove le spalle per la preoccupazione
all'idea di buttarsi da un aereo
sapete da piccolino io mi arrampicavo
ovunque armadi scaffali e mi buttavo giù
Non so perché lo facessi però lo facevo
mi buttavo nei divani sul letto Ecco per
fortuna l'anno scorso ho fatto un corso
di paracadutismo ho preso una mia
licenza di paracadutista e ho fatto 150
salti in un anno una buona media vi
spiego come funziona per chi era
preoccupato prima apri il portellone ti
sistemi mi sono lasciato bene e ti butti
a quel punto i primi secondi di vuoto si
scontrano con l'aria che ha una
consistenza un metro cubo d'aria ragazzi
pesa quasi un chilo
Quindi tu hai una velocità terminale che
è di 180 Km orari se fai poco attrito ti
mette a testa in giù 300 km all'ora a
testa in giù verso il suolo stupendo
sposti un braccio vai in una direzione
sposti le gambe vai in un'altra
direzione due paracadutisti in aria si
muovono tridimensionalmente
quando non saltavo da uno scaffale
all'altro
facevo video tutto il giorno a far video
i miei amici poveretti loro facevano da
protagonisti per i miei cortometraggi
orrendi Non sapevo nemmeno una
telecamera me la facevo prestare dal
vicino di casa con lo stesso vicino un
giorno mi fece vedere un film di una
trilogia che tutti quanti Conoscete il
primo capitolo di Matrix quel film mi ha
fatto diventare matto molto più di
quanto non lo sia già
Non faceva altro che parlare di quel
film settimane dopo settimane e mesi
dopo mesi non so quante volte l'ho
rivisto quel film in qualche modo aveva
avuto un impatto nella mia vita mi ero
reso conto che una narrazione può
portarti a compiere dei ragionamenti e
in qualche modo generare un effetto
palla di neve che si trasforma in una
valanga allora lì mi si è acceso una
lampadina ho detto nella vita voglio
fare Matrix
Voglio fare film come Matrix
ecco quando mi si chiede che lavoro
faccio io rispondo il content Creator se
sono gli altri a presentarmi invece
dicono youtuber il che non è proprio il
massimo perché ho 30 anni e questa cosa
viene spesso fraintesa
e
di che adesso un bel collegamento tra
paracadutismo e youtuber in questi 150
minuti di caduta libera in 150 salti si
è acceso una lampadina un'altra delle
emergenze dell'aereo No scherzo Non male
ancora no in casa c'ho il paracadute
Quindi tutto a posto
si è accesa la consapevolezza che salto
dopo salto
si è realizzato un meraviglioso
compromesso l'adrenalina si è
ridimensionata e mi sono reso conto di
questo compromesso
sentite bene gli esseri umani possono
fare quello che non potrebbero fare
e ora torniamo in qualche modo a quello
che vi ho detto all'inizio pensato un
paracadutista tu lo vedi da lontano vedi
un matto che sta chiedendo verso il
basso come un sasso e dici ma che sta
facendo sta cadendo al suolo ma
attraverso i suoi occhi lui sta volando
due paracadutisti si muovono te
ridimensionalmente attraverso i suoi
occhi sta facendo quello per cui la
natura umana non ci ha permesso di fare
volare
compromesso devo dire che non è una gran
parola perché la sezione è negativa ci
fa pensare al limite ci fa pensare ad
alternativa invece pensiamo a
compromessi in qualche modo come
sinonimo di equilibrio
se tu hai un obiettivo un obiettivo ben
preciso poi non arrivare in
quell'obiettivo Ma puoi trovare un
binario parallelo che va in quella
direzione non sarai esattamente
quell'obiettivo Ma la direzione di
valori sarà esattamente quella e vi
faccio qualche esempio visto che ho
fatto la grande premessa che in qualche
modo realizziamo dei sogni Se tu vuoi
diventare un insegnante
avvicinati il più possibile al concetto
di insegnamento e allora sarai un
insegnante Vuoi diventare un artista Beh
allora Aspettate che sia un gallerista
un critico d'arte a darti questa
etichetta tu diventi un artista nel
momento Esatto in cui sai di esserlo
pensi di essere un artista Sei un
artista punto vuoi viaggiare vuoi girare
il mondo beh servono risorse economiche
Certo ma siamo all'Aquila posto
bellissimo Prendi la bicicletta Esplora
qui dietro L'ho già visto vai un po' più
in là Lago di Garda l'hai visto No treno
regionale Esplora
mantieni fedeli il tuo valore di
esplorazione Poi man mano magari metti
il budget padroneggiare il mondo però
nel frattempo fai quello per cui dici È
il mio sogno di voler fare Vuoi fare il
chirurgo Studia per favore il più
possibile
però magari in quel caso il tuo valore è
quello di aiutare le persone e ci sono
mille modi per aiutarle Anzi ci sono
infiniti modi per aiutare le persone nel
frattempo studi e diventi chirurgo
oppure non diventi chirurgo Fai
qualcos'altro che non avevi avevi messo
in conto e magari ti rende felice allo
stesso modo o magari ancora oltre quel
binario parallelo
io sul web mi chiamo Emma Loru lavoro un
mese intero a una storia di 15-20 minuti
che poi carico online
su YouTube e questo fa di me uno
youtuber è vero agli occhi di qualcuno
sono uno youtuber trentenne che non hai
idee chiare magari su quello che sta
facendo e chissà Tra 10 anni cosa farà
ma attraverso i miei occhi io Sto
volando ho realizzato il sogno di quel
bambino che sognava di diventare regista
io so di essere un regista vi do questa
bella citazione di Walt Disney la
conoscete tutti se puoi sognarlo puoi
farlo
aggiungiamo che i limiti sono davvero
esclusivamente nella nostra testa
e se li osservi con gli occhi del te
stesso bambino e con una buona dose di
immaginazione puoi davvero superarli Mi
auguro che tutti voi realizzate il
vostro sogno Grazie
[Applauso]